hey 42 here as science and technology
continue to demystify the world around
us
we humans have a bad habit of assuming
we already know it all but the truth is
whilst we're discovering new things
about the nature of our universe
all the time we've barely scratched the
surface when it comes to knowing
everything there is to know there are
plenty of secrets out there
just waiting to be revealed and there's
a good chance we're going to find some
of them
in the most unexpected of places take
our very own solar system for example
it's easy to think that in 2021
thanks to millennia of stargazing and
the recent introduction of some pretty
nifty telescopes
we know exactly what's going on out
there and where
but the solar system is a big place
and once we travel past its eight
planets and
their 200 odd moons our understanding
of our own cosmic backyard is
surprisingly sketchy
so much so that some scientists believe
the furthest reaches of the solar system
hide a truly giant secret
an undiscovered ninth planet
and we aren't talking about some
diminutive planet
wannabe like pluto sorry pluto
or ceres if proponents of the planet
nine theory
are to be believed our solar system's
currently unidentified
ninth member is actually kind of a
monster
as much as ten times the mass of earth
and four times its radius
this postulated planet is portrayed as a
kind of
stealthy puppet master hinting got its
own existence
by subtly adjusting the orbits of
millions of distant asteroids
and dwarf planets with tendrils of
gravity
pretty intriguing right but how could
such a huge planet remain hidden in our
very
own solar system even today when modern
technology is helping us unravel the
inner workings of galaxies
halfway across the known universe to put
some context around that question
planet nine is thought to be hanging out
around 600 astronomical units
from the solar system's center an
astronomical unit
being the average distance between the
earth and
sun in the context of our solar system
600 au is a very very long way indeed
by comparison neptune's orbit puts it at
a mere
30 au from the sun but in the context of
the universe
where distances are usually measured in
light years
600 au is nothing the most distant
object from earth
ever detected is a galaxy known as gnz11
and it can be found a cool 32 billion
light years
from where you're sitting right now when
we train our telescopes on gnz11
we're seeing the universe as it was just
400 million years
after the big bang admittedly galaxies
are a tad bigger and brighter than
planets
but even the most distant exoplanets so
far detected
an exoplanet being any planet located
outside
of our own solar system are much much
further away than planets nine
first observed in 2006 sweeps 4
and sweeps 11 were found orbiting a star
in the constellation sagittarius they're
approximately 27
700 light years away from earth
which means the most distant planets
known to humans are around three million
times further away from earth than
planet nine is purported to be
think of it as the astronomical
equivalent of a
cryptozoologist discovering a tribe of
yetis
high up amongst the cloudy peaks of the
himalayas
without ever realizing one had been
living in his garden the whole time
and that slightly odd analogy leads me
back to the same question
is it really possible that a giant
planet
could be lurking in our solar system
without
us realizing before we get into all of
that
why do people believe planet nine even
exists in the first place
the search for our solar system's ninth
member began over 100 years ago
with a man named percival lowell who
became interested in astronomy after
reading a book about mars
most people who get into stargazing buy
themselves a book or two
and invest in some kind of simple
telescope but
lowell happens to be a member of that
particular cross-section of society
known as
rich people so he kicked off his new
hobby
by building himself an observatory on
the top of a mountain
in arizona lowell was a very smart guy
but it's fair to say he was probably
more famous for his crazy ideas
than his good ones on the crazier side
he believed there was life on mars and
that he'd found evidence to prove
it of course the idea that maybe life on
mars isn't particularly controversial
even today but lowell wasn't talking
about life
of the microscopic variety more of the
little green men
kind another of lowell's bold but
possibly mental ideas was his belief in
the existence of what he called
planet x which sounds like it should be
the birthplace of a marvel super villain
but was actually just a name he gave to
a hypothetical ninth planet
he believed was hiding in our solar
system
for all his her brain schemes lowell
appeared to have a pretty good
reason to suspect another planet might
be lurking somewhere
out there he determines that the orbits
of the outermost planets in the solar
system
uranus and neptune were slightly
different to what mathematics
predicted based on our existing
planetary model
almost as if they were being tugged off
course by some kind of
distant massive object planet x
lowell began searching for this elusive
celestial creature
in 1906. devoting the entirety of his
energy to the endeavor
but the years went by without success
it's said lol became so obsessed with
his quest
that his inability to find planet x
eventually killed him
though i should point out his coroner
saw things a little differently
recording glow's cause of death in 1916
as a stroke despite lowell's demise his
passion and a large chunk of his cash
ensured the search for planetex
continued
after his death and in 1930 the
breakthrough was finally made when clyde
tombaugh
discovered a new planet using the
telescope at lowell's very own
observatory
in arizona our solar system's newest
inductee
was duly named pluto partly in tribute
to percival lowell
its first two letters matching his
initials you see
you're only mental until you're right
as you can probably imagine the folks at
the lowell observatory were pretty
bloody pleased with themselves at this
development
and much slapping of backs and hiding of
fives ensued
but those good vibes didn't last long
because it turned out the reason it had
taken decades to find pluto
was that it was very very faint and very
slow moving across the sky
suggesting it was a lot further out than
the other planets
and probably pretty small these
suspicions were confirmed in 1978
when pluto's moon sharon was discovered
allowing astronomers to definitively
determine the planet's mass
as it happened poor old pluto was a
tiddler
just one-sixth the mass of our own moon
such a diminutive distant planet would
have been about as capable of knocking
planetary heavyweights
uranus and neptune out of their
predicted orbits
as i would be of knocking anthony joshua
onto the canvas
to become heavyweight champion of the
world i.e
not very it was clear pluto was not the
plenitex percival was looking for
but wait a minute if pluto wasn't
causing neptune and uranus's orbital
oddities
that meant something else was right
actually wrong because it turns out the
whole
dodgy orbits of neptune and uranus
theory
has been one giant cosmic red herring
all along
a fact that was proven in 1989 when
voyager 2
visited neptune and discovered we'd
misjudged
its mass when astronomers plugged the
correct values into those complicated
astronomical equations they're all so
fond of they discovered the orbits of
both uranus and
neptune had been exactly where they were
supposed to be
the whole time and that was officially
the end of planet x
the theorized ninth planet in our solar
system
had never been there in the first place
if i'd made this video a decade ago
it would probably have ended right here
and i would have been up a suit and down
a mustache
obviously but over the last 10 years
astronomers have begun
whispering about planet nine once more
because whilst
lowell's belief in a hidden ninth planet
turned out to have been founded
on a massive mistake
weirdly enough it seems the conclusion
this false trail led him to
may just have been correct after all
perhaps the best
known planet nine theory today was put
forward by astronomers
constantine battigan and michael brown
in
2016. and their hypothesis isn't all
that different to lowell's from 100
years before
batagan and brown had also discovered
orbital anomalies
that were difficult to explain based on
our current understanding of the solar
system
though in this case the orbits were of
extreme
trans-neptunian objects ethnos
rather than planets ethnos are a group
of solar system satellites orbiting the
sun far out beyond neptune in the most
distant parts of a region called the
kuiper belt
we think there are literally billions of
these asteroids out there
though to date we've only found and
catalogued around
2 000 of them the ones we found so far
seem to share some pretty unusual
properties
we're talking orbits that are
perpendicular to those of the planets
and almost everything else in the solar
system orbits that travel the opposite
way around the sun
to almost everything else in the solar
system
and perhaps most significantly of all
orbits that seem to be clustered
together in a very specific
very non-random way so
what's causing all this weirdness you
guessed it planet nine is back
considering how badly things went with
the first astronomical expedition to
find planet nine
it's easy to be skeptical about these
claims and
plenty of people are after all it is a
bit of a weird coincidence that
two completely separate observatories
100 years apart
have led two very different sets of
scientists to believe in the same
hidden giant planet far out in the solar
system
but vatican and brown are certainly no
crackpots out to make gravitational
waves
they're incredibly well respected in
their fields and have a string of
accolades to their names
constantine vatican was named on the
forbes list of 30 scientists
under 30 who are changing the world
back in 2015 unpopular science magazine
named him one of 2016's most brilliant
people
mike brown on the other hand is
ironically enough
the self-styled man who kills pluto
having been instrumental in the
reclassification
of our solar system's pretender to the
planet 9 crown
to a dwarf planet back in 2006.
he also co-discovered a dwarf planet of
his own
iris in 2005. with
most radical scientific theories that
threaten to
fundamentally change our understanding
of established facts
you have huge numbers of skeptics on one
side of the argument
and a few eccentric and passionate
believers on the other
a bit like lowell and his belief in
martians
but when it comes to planet nine both
sides of the debate
are populated with bonafide geniuses
and all of them seem to be talking sense
when they argue
for or against the existence of planet
nine
so how are we mere mortals supposed to
figure out what to believe
well as carl sagan once said
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence
and whilst there is some interesting
evidence pointing to the existence of
planet nine
to call it extraordinary would be
stretching the truth
just a little bit even basically and
brown themselves concede
they can't be sure planet 9 exists until
they actually manage to
find the damn thing which brings us back
to our all-important question
if planet nine really is out there
why haven't we found it yet i mentioned
earlier that the two most distant
exoplanets so far located
are three million times further away
from earth
than planet nine is supposed to be but
as is often the case with very big
numbers
it's hard to picture what that really
means
so let's shrink it down to human scale
if
you representing the earth we're
standing in dublin
ireland and both sweeps4 and sweeps 11
were in moscow where do you think you
would find
planet nine the answer is
also in dublin and in fact rather closer
than that
it would be less than one meter from the
tip of your nose
when you put it in those terms it's easy
to assume that
if we haven't found planet nine yet
that's because
it isn't there it should be staring us
in the face
literally it's easy to assume that
but neither of us are asses so we
probably
shouldn't in reality the fact we've been
able to locate such distant exoplanets
has no real relevance to the hunt for
planet nine
we found sweeps4 and sweeps 11 using a
method called
transit photometry which involves
monitoring a whole bunch of stars for a
long period of time
and watching out for any small dips in
the intensity of light given
off which might indicate a planet
crossing or
transiting the star's surface we use
these kinds of techniques because
exoplanets are essentially
invisible to us here on earth they
simply aren't
bright enough to be seen directly so
we're only able to detect them by
watching out for
any impact they may be having on their
parent
star that makes searching for exoplanets
very hit and miss and when i say hit and
miss
what i really mean is a whole lot of
missing
interspersed with very very occasional
hits to detect an exoplanet through
transit photometry
the earth the planet and its parent star
have to be perfectly aligned otherwise a
transit
won't take place if you were to pick a
random star similar to our own somewhere
out there in space
the odds of us being able to detect an
earth-like planet
orbiting it at 1au using transit
photometry
would be a little under half a percent
think of transit photometry as a
brute-force approach to fighting
exoplanets
monitor thousands of stars over the
course of a few years
and you're bound to locate a few
exoplanets here and there
despite the relatively long odds if
on the other hand you wanted to find a
specific
planet orbiting a single star transit
photometry
would be next to useless in our own
solar system
transit photometry would only be able to
help us find the planets with tighter
orbits than our own
mercury and venus basically and both of
those are visible with the naked eye
when it comes to searching for planet
nine and other distant objects out in
the kuiper belt
and beyond we pretty much have to rely
on regular old telescopes
which makes the whole thing a seriously
tricky business
earlier this year it was confirmed that
the most distant object currently known
in our solar system is a planetoid
called
far far out which is just 140
au from the sun that's only about a
quarter of the way to planet nine
admittedly far far out is also far
far smaller than planet nine is supposed
to be
but still the point is we have never
detected an object as distant as planet
within our own solar system not even
close
which means that just because we haven't
found it yet
that doesn't mean it isn't out there
the solar system is very very big
and the vast majority of it by volume is
still
basically unknown to us vatican and
brown believe planet nine is
so dim it will only just be visible with
our current technology
given perfect atmospheric conditions
which may only come around a few times
per year
so for now all we can do is try
to predict where we think it should be
then train our best telescopes on that
part of the sky
and hope earlier i compared not being
able to find
planet nine in a world where we've
already tracked down planets
tens of light years from earth to
finding yetis in the himalayas
without realizing one's been living in
the garden
but in truth that analogy is a little
bit off
because it turns out if there is a yeti
in our garden
he's chronically shy and fond of
dressing up in full-on
camo gear whereas the few yetis we found
out there in the himalayas
just happens to be in exactly the right
place at the right time
and we're yodeling at the top of their
lungs i should point out there are other
possible explanations for what might be
causing the
unusual orbits of the ethnos we've found
so far
perhaps the most interesting of which is
the idea that a black hole
hidden within our own solar system might
be to blame
before you start worrying the earth is
about to be sucked into a giant cosmic
vacuum cleaner
the black hole in question would be a
tiny primordial black hole
and as yet purely theoretical variety
that may have formed soon after the big
bang this particular flavor of black
hole is much smaller than your average
collapsed star type being only about the
size of a grapefruit
but with a mass five to ten times that
of the earth
as interesting as both this and the
planet nine theory sound
the truth may actually be far simpler
remember how the evidence leading lowell
to believe in planet x turned out to be
a red herring
well it's quite possible that could be
the case here too
vatican and brown are basing their
assumptions on the very small sample
size
of etinos we've been able to study so
far we're talking tens out of the total
population
in the billions and drawing big
conclusions
planet-sized ones in fact from small
data sets is a dangerous business
no matter how compelling they may seem
on the surface
ultimately in science the burden of
truth lies with whoever's making the
contentious claim
and for now basically and brown haven't
been able to prove their theory
they do however believe it's only a
matter of time
so i guess that means all we need to do
is watch this space literally
thanks for watching you can get your
hands on my book stick a flag in it over
on amazon or on audible links to both in
the description below
thank you